good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on Sky News
Tuesday morning it's been called the
Battle of Britain England and Wales will
go head to head this evening in a game
that will decide both their World Cup
Futures wells will need to beat England
for the first time in nearly 40 years to
be in with a Chance of keeping their
dreams alive and hope for a draw between
the USA and Iran with millions of people
expected to tune in tonight we'll have
more on that for you in just a few
moments time also the very latest from
Ali
epic
yeah
good morning from the World Cup in Qatar
the big match is just 12 hours away
we'll be speaking some England and Welsh
fans ahead of The Showdown later tonight
Golden Era is over Rishi sunak signals a
new approach to China and criticizes
beijing's Crackdown on anti-lockdown
protesters
an uneasy quiet here in Shanghai as
police came out in force at the protest
hot spots
the government removes a section of its
Online safety Bill technology firms will
no longer have to remove material which
is legal but harmful
the Samaritans call it a hugely backward
step but the government says not doing
so could have damaged free speech
Russia shells dozens of settlements
across Southern Ukraine President
zielinski says there have been more than
250 strikes in the last week alone
and I'll bring you the latest from the
capital Kiev as the president warns of
more Dark Days Ahead saying the
airstrikes will continue until Moscow
runs out of missiles
concerns about the cost of Christmas
with a new report suggesting nearly one
in five of us will be using a food bank
this festive period
Hawaii's Big Island shakes is the
world's largest active volcano erupts
for the first time in nearly four
decades
[Music]
I know where millions of us are going to
be about seven o'clock tonight it's been
called the Battle of Britain England and
Wales going head-to-head this evening in
a game that will decide both their World
Cup Futures wells will need to be
England for the first time in nearly 40
years to be in with a Chance of keeping
their dream alive and hope for a draw
between the USA and Iran with millions
of people as I said expected to tune in
tonight the National Grid had briefly
considered triggering their emergency
blackout prevention plan this evening
although it says that won't now be
necessary let's get more should we with
uh Ali who's standing by for us in Doha
hello to you ali um so who's going to
win
good morning it's just gone 10 a.m here
in Qatar 7 A.M in the UK in 12 hours
time the fixture will have just kicked
off Millions as you say will be watching
back home in the UK but also thousands
of fans from both sides who have made
the trip uh over here to Qatar to watch
the match and we're joined by four of
them now I won't give you my predictions
yet k for the match but we'll get it
from these four Hayden and Luke are both
English fans and Jalal and tamjit are
both Welsh fans so let's start with you
guys first because you've let's be
honest got the tougher ask tonight
um you've watched all the match actually
world's matches so far how's it going
how's the tournament been for you if
it's not what we expected I think the
first game with the news got the better
with us the second half we kind of found
our feet and um we're lucky not to get
the win against Iran I think uh one
o'clock kickoff he played two Iran's
advantage and we looked a bit lethargic
but against England today you know
obviously he's a must win um we have to
go we're gonna go for a two-nil win and
hopefully U.S USA drove with Iran we
both go through it's kind of gloves off
tonight isn't it but then you've got you
know there's nothing for Wells to lose
there's huge support and it's a big
tournament so
you know form goes out the window in
many ways well that's what we've got to
Hope I mean if if we're taking form into
consideration we don't stand a chance
tonight because we let's be honest we've
not had a great tournament so far but I
mean like you said we hope form goes out
the window it's a derby at the end of
the day and it's something that we're
going to try and
try and make sure that we get the three
points and unlike JaVale I don't want to
see a draw for for USA and Iran I'd like
to see USA win so we bought the only
Wales goes through uh hey Luke paper
it should be straightforward for England
I mean
it's the local Derby Wales I mean they
probably see it as big a rivalry than we
do
um but I think we've got the best chance
we've just got to go out like we did
against Iran I mean the USA game we
weren't good enough we're pretty boring
um but I think Bishop like we did with
us around then it shouldn't be easy
games today would you like to see South
go and make a few changes he's under a
lot of pressure to pay perhaps rest a
few players I'm fine with the starting
lineup starting the same uh if we start
like we're doing that Iran game that was
a Dream It's like a dream come true I
think everyone's frustration with the
USA game wasn't necessarily the way to
start this so we didn't change it when
things weren't working and that was a
bit frustrating to see even just
changing one person two person could
bring on that energy and you know what
that first half when it wasn't great and
we came out to start the second half and
we're under the cost for 15 minutes I
just couldn't believe that we still
weren't making changes to conceding Corn
after corn after corner and then he
slowly dripped for those changes on I
found that so frustrating so hopefully
even if we start like we did against USA
again he makes changes a little bit
earlier that'd be my Hope anyway and
just changing tax slightly you guys both
live out here
um you're English but you live in Qatar
how's it been how have you found the
tournament I think this is great I think
it really has been really good
um everything they've set up for the
World Cup specifically uh has been spot
on all the fan festivals all this stuff
going along on the Corniche all the
stadiums as well everything around there
has been great okay very quickly I'll go
through you one by one score predictions
for tonight 3-1 England two nil
on the Welsh side of things
one nil to Wales okay fantastic okay a
couple of statistics for me uh England
Wells first made in 1879 it was a 2-1
win to England uh today will be their
103rd meeting uh the only time that
they've met in the tournament is Euro
2016 England won but Wales were the side
that progressed through to the last 16.
so you know anything could happen
tonight uh we'll wait and see 12 hours
as I say until kickoff I hope looking at
other stuff for you a pitch Invader
briefly stole the show during last
night's Portugal Uruguay match uh he ran
onto the field waving a rainbow flag
before being removed by security his
shirt read save Ukraine on the front and
respect for Iranian women on the back
he's been identified as Mario Ferry a
football player from Italy who has a
reputation for pitch protests
of course we'll bring you more on what's
happening in Qatar throughout the course
of the program which you'll be watching
the game uh tonight and I'm sure you've
got your views on who you would like to
win you can tweet us if you would like
to at Cape early use the hashtag k
Burley shareit with some of our viewers
later on meantime let's tell you about
Rishi sunak he says the Golden Era
between the UK and China is over and
he's called for a new approach to the
Chinese government the prime minister
also criticized beijing's response to
recent protests saying instead of
listening to their demands Beijing chose
to crack down further the wave of
demonstrations against the country's
strict covid measures have created a
challenge to the Chinese Communist party
not seen since the chairman Square
Crackdown
now let's be clear the so-called Golden
Era is over
along with a naive idea that trade would
automatically lead to social and
political reform
but nor should we rely on simplistic
Cold War rhetoric
we recognize China poses a systemic
challenge to our values and interests
a challenge that grows more acute as it
moves towards even greater
authoritarianism
instead of listening to their people's
protests the Chinese government has
chosen to crack down further
well updating us throughout the course
of the week was Helena she's with us now
in Shanghai hello to you Helen and when
you spoke to us yesterday morning you
said it was very tense there what's it
like now
well I think it's that atmosphere
continuing K I think there was a really
interesting story that played out over
the course of yesterday when we woke up
and when we spoke to you yesterday this
incredibly high tension particularly in
those protest hot spots there was an
incredible police presence really no one
could do anything without multiple
people being on them quite quickly even
lifting a phone up to take a few
pictures was enough to be sort of pulled
aside and spoken to it really was
incredibly tense but then as night fell
and as the evening Drew on it was almost
as if the authorities took a weird sort
of sigh of relief it was almost as if
they're extremely heavy Crackdown
earlier in the day had given people the
message that quite frankly coming out
just wasn't an option yesterday and
actually police were just a little bit
less
um sort of a fair not effective not
quite the right word but they were a
little bit less forthcoming in the
evening we were able to take some
pictures and there were a few really
poignant moments of defying and protest
just a small sunflower left on a Bollard
we saw one man who boldly stood right
next to police and just stood there
watching and then out of his bag he took
a notebook that was essentially just
full of white pieces of paper and
remember okay that symbol of the white
piece of paper held up is becoming a
real symbol of these protests and he
just stood there with his notebook of
white pieces of paper he was there for
about half an hour until police arrested
him but symbols like this showed that
the strength of feeling has absolutely
not gone away here the fact that people
aren't coming out as much largely
because of the Crackdown but also
perhaps because it's a Tuesday rather
than the weekend it's actually an
unseasonably cold and wet day here in
Shanghai as well today but look I don't
think just because voices have been
temporarily quietened here in Shanghai
and elsewhere across China I don't think
they have been silenced forever I think
this sense of feeling about covid-19 and
the excessive zero covert measures that
still exist in this country absolutely
continue worth saying there is a
Authority press conference this
afternoon where we will get a bit of an
update about that covid-19 response we
don't really expect anything dramatic to
have shifted and but people will be
watching it closely nonetheless I wonder
what the authorities there Helena will
think about our prime minister's speech
at mansion house last night
well I think frankly K that's likely to
be met with a bit of a shrug here in
Beijing you know Xi Jinping the
president he's been in power a decade
here and he is well used to politicians
coming to power in other European and
American and Western countries wanting
to say their tough bit on China I think
frankly it makes very little difference
to his agenda which is about China
taking what he considers to be an
ascendant and rightful place as a
central it's a leading Global power in
the world he is unashamed about China's
more assertive role on the foreign stage
and he is unashamed about the path that
he's taking this country on so look
frankly I think here in China sort of
politicians wanting to be seen to talk
tough on China doesn't make a huge
amount of difference and doesn't really
land here with the politicians in
particular okay thank you thanks a lot
now the government has made new changes
to its Online safety Bill designed to
protect children while watering down
plants to make big Tech remove content
which is legal but deemed as harmful as
standing by for us uh now hello to you
Sadia uh at the culture media and Sport
this is what a digital as well I almost
forgot that but it is written in big
letters behind you this bill keeps
changing
thank you
yes the Online safety bill has faced
repeated delays but it is due to go back
to Parliament next week with a key
change that is that a bit about the
removal by social media companies of
content that is legal but harmful that's
been removed so that is content for
example that might glorify Eating
Disorders or challenge the covid vaccine
always misogynistic in nature for
example things that Free Speech
campaigners had argued would be used by
governments and tech companies to censor
certain groups of people now what tech
companies must do is provide tools so
that the user can essentially censor
themselves so all of the content will be
online but it is down to the user to
pick and choose what they want to see
and what they don't want to see it is
what a big it is a big win for free
speech campaigners who had long argued
that the bill was too restrictive but it
is what charities including the
Samaritans are calling a huge step
backwards the government is calling it a
triple Shield protection online
objection that also allows for Free
Speech but it will no doubt create lots
of debate after today's announcement and
quickly before I go a few of the other
changes that are coming through for the
Online safety Bill one of them is a new
age verification policy so that children
aren't exposed to content that is
intended for adults there's also
something in there about social media
companies not being able to remove users
or accounts without due process and more
powers for ofcom which becomes the new
tech regulator okay thank you
still to come on the program for you
this morning joined by the culture
secretary Michelle Donald to ask her
more about that Online safety Bill
building up to tonight's England Wales
game at the World Cup speaking to the
former lion former Arsenal player too as
well of course and Labor's Shadow work
and pension secretary Jonathan Ashworth
will be with me soon after eight o'clock
the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski has warned the country faces
dark cold days ahead as Russia continues
to strike its infrastructure saying it
would not end until Moscow runs out of
missiles standing by for us in Kiev this
morning is Deborah as you saw in our
opening sequence hello to you Deborah
he's preparing the nation for a
challenging winter
he is and he did make that those remarks
over the weekend about the threat of new
strikes including here in the capital
it's been a relatively new tactic by
Russia failing to make ground on the
battlefield turning people's homes into
a new front line by targeting his
missiles against Ukraine's Power and
Water Supplies it's been happening in
these waves of strikes over recent weeks
it seems to be almost once a week these
strikes come it's very notable
um being back in the capital since I was
last here back in late August and
previously you'd have every day two or
three times a day these Air Raid Sirens
going off warnings of of new Russian
missile attacks and I've been here since
Friday we haven't heard a single air
raid siren and I've been told it's
because now the Russians are far more
targeted and when they're using their
missiles and instead of maybe sending a
few at a time they send a huge number at
a time because they're trying to get
through Ukraine's increasingly effective
air defense systems and so yes here in
the capital officials have been working
very hard to restore Power and Water
supplies for people but at the same time
they're doing that they know that
another missile strike is expected and
it's a it's a horrendous way to live we
went to Just One Last Point these
invincibility points that are being put
up around the city to enable people to
get some heat to get some power for
their mobile phones to get a hot drink
when they're sitting in their own homes
without power when it's freezing cold
many people here are young as young
children it's the very elderly and it's
a desperate situation some of them can't
leave to somewhere safer they don't want
to leave they want to stay here but it
really is a new Battlefront for people
to have to endure
first lady here in the United Kingdom at
the moment we saw on the steps of dining
Street actually yesterday the Christmas
tree lights are being lit up she was
with our own uh first lady
um she talked earlier on in the day
about rape being used as a tool of War
by Russia
yes it's another horrific dimension of
this war as with many wars unfortunately
people being targeted Russian troops
accused of of raping of raping women men
even children and these crimes are
emerging as Ukrainian forces are able to
liberate areas and then people feel as
though they are able to come out and
speak and it really is an area a
horrendous crime in this war that as you
say the first lady is Keen to highlight
and of course efforts underway the
prosecution service here in Ukraine with
help from the International Community
trying to gather the evidence to be able
to hold those responsible to justice
that is really key yes they are fighting
this war yes they're determined to win
but at the end of that they want to
ensure that those that committed these
crimes these horrific crimes are held to
account
okay for now thank you thanks so much
indeed and we'll be speaking to the um
Deputy first Minister uh coming up and
also we'll be talking
um actually to Julia and uh that will be
around about uh 9 20. and a reminder
tonight that we have a special
documentary that is uh Putin's Obsession
the fight for Ukraine that's at 7 pm
here on Sky News
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now and people can now
use an Anonymous hotline to report
corrupt or abusive metropolitan police
officers the force has been criticized
for a series of failures not least the
racist and sexist behavior of serving
officers the hotline is the first of its
kind in the UK and will be run by Crime
Stoppers
we are aware that recent months and over
the whole of the last year there have
been far too many cases which have led
to the public quite understandably
losing faith losing trust in the
metropolitan police we are on the front
foot to put that right we're on the
front foot to rebuild trust and this
hotline the first of its kind asking for
the Public's help is a step forward we
hope in driving up standards in the
metropolitan police and representing if
I may the thousands of dedicated
officers and staff who would risk their
lives to the public every single day
and a man is 30 is critically wounded
after being shot by police in Somerset
officers went to a house near Western
super mare as part of an investigation
into possible Firearms offenses the
independent office for police conduct
will investigate what happened
it's joined now by the culture secretary
Michelle Donald hi it's good to see you
thank you joining us on the program so
I've got to that page where I need to
put my glasses on so you'll have to
forgive me
um talk to me about this new Online
safety bill um you say is going to
protect children but we've strengthened
it for children so everything that was
in it before in relation to children
that means that if the content is
illegal it has to go it means that if
it's harmful but still legal it has to
go and companies will face a humongous
fines if they breach these terms up to
10 of their Global turnover the ways
that we've strengthened it that I've
done are we're making sure that they
have to adhere to their age restrictions
we know they all set 13 as an age but we
don't that they don't enforce it so you
get 10 year olds 11 year olds 12 year
olds on those platforms so what we say
is they have to have mechanisms by which
to stop kids younger going like age
Assurance age verification Etc and they
have to explain to the public and to
parents how they're doing that in their
terms and conditions and again if they
fail to do that they could face the
sanctions we're also saying that the
regulator of com has to work with the
children's Commissioners that children's
Voice is coming out and when social
media platforms do risk assessments into
illegal content and harmful content they
also have to provide summaries uh
publicly so everybody knows again what
they're saying so that they can no
longer be a closed shop they can no
longer be these nameless faceless
Executives in Silicon Valley that are
making decisions about your children
everybody else's children sure I mean
we've been chatting to the shadow
culture actually Lucy Powell she says
it's a major weakening of the bill
replacing the prevention of harm with an
emphasis on Free Speech undermines in
quoting her the very purpose of this
bill oh I'm sure she hasn't properly had
time to to go through the bill because
when she does she will understand
actually what we've done is strengthen
it have run through the strengthens for
children then for adults we've
introduced a triple shield first shield
is if the content is illegal has to go I
before second Shield is if it's contrary
to their terms and conditions it has to
go we know that covers the vast majority
of things when we think back to 100 with
the footballers in opposed to euros with
the racist horrendous abuse they got
that was either a legal or contrary to
terms of conditions they just don't
enforce them and versus a Monday versus
a Tuesday it's a different kind of
approach and we're going to stop that
from happening and the third corporate
harmful but not illegal because of
course your team so what we're doing is
we're removing legal but harmful but the
third Shield that we're doing is a
safeguarding mechanism a further safety
net so that it empowers individuals to
have more control over the content that
they see it gives them the choice so
it's freedom of choice and freedom of
speech whilst also offering those three
Shields of protection why take out
harmful but not illegal because it had
very very concerning
um uh impact potentially on Free Speech
there are unintended consequences
associated with it it was really the
anchor that was preventing this bill
from getting off the the ground it was a
creation of a quasi-legal category
between illegal and legal that's not
what a government should be doing it's
confusing it would create a different
kind of set of rules online to offline
in the legal sphere personally I think
you know if we all agree that stuff
should be illegal let's make it illegal
that's what we've done with this bill
now for the first time ever the
promotion of self-harm will be made
illegal and that's something that we've
added to this bill in the last couple of
months whilst I've had an organization
that knows a lot about that is the
Samaritans they say taking legal but
um uh harmful but not legal out is a
hugely backward step
um but they've also campaigned for the
promotion of self-harm to be made
illegal which is something that we've
done and as I said before we've
introduced this triple Shield so if the
content is illegal it goes if it's
contrary to their terms and conditions
it goes and then there's an additional
safety mechanism where platforms do have
to provide more choice to individuals
over the content that they see so this
is all encompassing but fundamentally
it's about children and we're really
strengthening those aspects how are you
feeling about Elon Musk and his new look
Twitter well look he's a an individual
that's purchased a private business but
it's important that we have those
Safeguard mechanisms around it so and no
matter what direction he wants to take
Twitter in we will have this triple
shield in place for adults and he will
have to adhere to the new rules for
children to safeguard them yeah what do
you think about some of the choice
characters that he's allowing back on
Twitter again you know that is a
decision for him I do believe in free
speech I passionately believe it is the
Cornerstone of our democracy but I also
believe in Freedom of Choice which is
why we've added that Safeguard mechanism
so you will have more Choice over the
content that you see I believe that
people shouldn't be subjected to Illegal
content and and I believe that if a
company is going to say that they're
going to do something they should
actually do it and they shouldn't be
conning people in terms of conditions
that aren't actually then enforced
um it's a big day today as you know for
both England and Wales fans as we know
one of your ministers Stuart Andrew the
sports Minister openly gay he's going to
Qatar he's wearing his one love and he
says do you support him in that 100 I
support the uh the campaign behind it
and the sentiment behind the one love
armband and I believe in us being able
to stand up for our values and I'm proud
that he's going to wear that would you
wear one if you went yes I think I would
actually
okay I'm only asking because Tony Blair
has said we shouldn't be pushing Kata
too far because they invest very heavily
in the UK been doing a bit of research
on that with the team this morning their
own Harrods The Shard
um the Savoy 20 stake in Heathrow 14
stake in Sainsbury's we don't really
want to upset them
well I mean I think that that this is
not about pushing them this is about
standing up your own values and uh and
your country's values I fully backed uh
the English and the Welsh teams uh
desire to wear the the bands too
obviously they were curtailed from doing
that because they would have faced very
punitive sport sanctions but you know
it's imperative that we use our voice
that we stand up for our values not just
in the UK but on the global stage okay
given that Golden Era of relations with
China is over says Rishi sunak yesterday
is China a threat or a challenge these
days because you described it as a
challenge last night in the summer when
I interviewed him he talked about it as
a threat I think we can get a little bit
hung up on the semantics here but what
he said last night was it's um does
present strategic challenges and he
talked about the fact that we've got to
have our eyes open we can't forget the
fat or underestimate the fact that
they're a massive Global player and that
we do need to engage with them but at
the same time we've got to do that as I
say with our eyes open they have two
percent strategic charges and we will um
be updating the integration did review
in the spring so we don't need to see
them as a threat though well as he said
last night they're a strategic challenge
but let's not threat in the summer well
let's I mean I think we're a little bit
talking of semantics here type of
challenge I mean they're very similar a
similar language too much on on the
prime minister's choice of phrase you
know he did a very detailed speech last
night where he outlined his position I
see some of my colleagues there's a
challenge but I don't see them as a
threat well look uh he outlined his his
full position uh last night the full
speeches is available to read I think it
was very comprehensive and clear where
he was coming from and we'll be updating
the integrated review in the new year I
just saw in the papers this morning that
you were commenting on the fact that
Westminster Hall had been damaged during
the Queens lying in state because the
carpet was glued to the floor how much
is it going to cost to fix it I don't
think we have a figure at the moment but
obviously we did everything we could to
make sure that
um people were able to pay their
respects and mourn the queen and and it
was very successful in that vat
um and also you know they were they were
able to participate and felt like they
thought whatever the costume was worth
it well no I wouldn't say that but I
don't think anybody's questioning
whether people should have had the
opportunity to see the queen but don't
come along with Gorilla Glue and stick
down the carpet look I don't think
anybody's questioning that people should
have had the opportunity to to say
goodbye to our late Monarch who was
arguably one of the best in our history
as a nation
um any damage will will of course be
covered and I'm sure that we can come
back to you with these advocacy okay I'm
sure other glue companies are available
just to just to be it's good to see
thank you very much a lot bear with us
one second thanks a lot uh time now for
a look at the morning's papers for you
and the guardian leads with the prime
minister's speech at the Lord Murs
banquet where he described China as a
systemic challenge to our values and
interests the eye says Rishi sunak could
soon preempt a rebellion from within his
own party by lifting the ban on onshore
wind farms the Metro reports on the
first lady of Ukraine who told a
conference to address sexual violence
during conflict saying that Russian
soldiers are being ordered from the top
to use rape as a weapon of war the time
says social media companies are to be
told to protect young people or pay the
price
tomorrow is with us quick whisk through
there with the culture secretary
thoughts that's right so the online
harms bill it's been a four-year battle
to get these laws to protect children
and protect adults online to Parliament
still not happened yet but Michelle
Donald the culture actually thinks that
she can do it by taking out some wording
that has proved very controversial legal
but harmful the idea that there is
content out there promoting self-harm
prom promoting eating disorders and
promoting misogyny for example that is
harmful but it's not actually illegal
now a lot of MPS said this was going too
far she said to you there that there
were concerning effects on Free Speech
therefore she's taken out that wording
but she says she's toughening it up in a
number of other ways in the I and the
plan is that this comes back to
Parliament next week that wording having
been taken out and the government
manages to make it law she hopes by the
summer of next year now campaigners and
the labor party say
um this is go this is this is watered
down that she's taken out some of the
key
um things in there which protect people
and that therefore um she's had to bow
to her critics now Michelle Donald says
that if this content is on there
um it it will still these these this
will still apply to children adults can
filter out content they don't want to
see and if companies breach their own
terms and conditions they will be fined
these enormous fines will this work in
practice that's the big question whether
people are still able to actually report
it and actually see the companies take
action okay tomorrow for now thanks so
much I need tomorrow's take at nine
o'clock and at nine o'clock on Thursday
joined by union leaders to answer your
questions as the country faces a wave of
strikes not seen in a generation you can
tweet me at K Burley with your questions
got an email address for you as well
which will update you on very shortly
indeed
other protests in China represent the
strongest public Defiance of XI
jinping's leadership and of beijing's
Authority for 30 years the unrest
erupted from frustration over president
xi's zero covered policy with the China
being the only major economy to still
have Draconian restrictions Chinese
government has also been accused of
piling resources into testing and
subsequent lockdowns rather than
focusing on rolling out vaccines joining
us now John delaurie a professor of
Chinese studies at Yoni University in
South Korea good to see you thanks so
much indeed for joining us what do you
make of what you're seeing in China at
the moment with a process
it's really quite astonishing uh you
know I'm someone who's who's spent time
in China live there on and off and
traveled since the early 90s I missed
1989 and in my experience uh there's
really nothing like this in terms of uh
you know major cities across the country
uh public demonstrations on what are
essentially political issues
um it's it's just uh nothing in recent
memories so we're all trying to process
you know understand exactly where this
came from uh and and where it's going
obviously the covid policy is the
primary focal point of it but if you
listen to the the slogans that are being
used by students on campus and also you
know just on street corners uh it's
getting into political stuff I mean the
main phrase you hear is we want freedom
uh which uh which goes beyond just the
lockdown it raises broader political
questions
yeah yeah why why do you think the
authorities are struggling to contain
this latest outbreak
I think it got them by surprise you know
uh I mean we shouldn't underestimate the
sophistication of what's called China's
surveillance State you know it's a great
new book out by that topic and and it's
true I mean the the party and the
Chinese government has put a massive
amount of resources into building up
this uh this surveillance system and and
of course they're willing to use very
harsh repression to Target anyone who
speaks out politically uh but they
really you know all those cameras didn't
catch the change in people's hearts and
Minds where there was this deep
discontent that's been brewing at least
all year on places like Shanghai since
the big lockdown in the spring uh you
know people are really upset uh I think
part of it is that Xi Jinping and the
Elites in the party were so fixated on
their recent party Congress they were
paying attention to all the power games
at the top and trying to make that a
seamless transition into his third
five-year term in power I think they
weren't paying attention to the street
you know and just how upset people are
so uh from the look of it I think they
were caught off guard the public
security looks like they were caught off
guard didn't know quite how to handle it
now they'll be you know now that the
immediate protests have cooled off
they'll be trying to move in and we'll
see what they do next but I I don't
think they saw this coming any more than
most outside experts did what is the way
out of this for presidency
well he's facing some very difficult
calls because he is closely associated
with this harsh uh lockdown policy so if
he loosens the policy he's going to have
to do it in a face-saving manner you
know their system's pretty good at that
too so I think that we could see them
start to move in that direction they've
got public health problems though
because by most estimates especially the
older population is not sufficiently
vaccinated so they could face a real
epidemiological problem that other
countries are less worried about as as
we've you know reached a certain degree
not have heard immunity but so many of
us getting covered by now which is not
the case in China so he's got very hard
and the party has very hard decisions to
make just on the policy question of uh
loosening covet but beyond that
um you know in terms of his basic
legitimacy this is not what he wanted at
the beginning of of a third term and it
suggests that there's some pretty deep
discontent in his country so if he's a
smart politician he's also going to have
to do work to essentially restore some
public faith in his leadership and
whether he's capable of that is very
much an open question and more generally
what is the um Crackdown doing for the
reputation of China on the world stage
well look if you review public opinion
polls from where you are in the UK to
where I sit in South Korea I mean just
about globally we've seen this steady
slide in terms of how publics feel about
China you know what they're seeing
coming out of the Chinese government I
should say in particular and so this is
on the one hand you know I think
actually it gives a little bit of global
Faith because you hear the voice of
Chinese people there's a certain sense
of solidarity uh that they have the same
hopes and dreams that we have
um outside and that their voice is just
so squash so in a strange way I think
it's almost something positive in terms
of our ability to hear from from young
Chinese people uh for example but as far
as the image of the government it looks
very bad and now we're mostly expecting
you know the state to kind of loudly or
quietly start to crack down and if they
pursue that path that's going to be yet
more of a of a negative impression that
it leaves on the world okay Professor
good to talk to you thank you thank you
I want to stick with the China and our
data and forensics a correspondent
that's Tom Cheshire used to be in China
as you know has been looking at what's
driving the kovic crisis and the
lockdowns in the country
the Chinese Communist party has boxed
itself into a dilemma people want an end
to Draconian zero covered restrictions
but easing those restrictions could lead
to a wave of deaths because the country
is simply not prepared kovitzer has
started nearly three years ago in Wuhan
in January 2020. Sky News was there on
the ground there's a bit of confusion as
you might expect given this shutdown
announcement came in the middle of the
night we know the train station the
airport they're both closed we're not
sure about the roads we've seen reports
that they are being blocked by police so
we're going to try and find a way out of
Wuhan
the idea that lockdowns would still be
happening three years later would have
been extraordinary but in the early
stages of the pandemic it worked China's
death rate has been low throughout you
can barely see it on this graph
especially when you compare it to the UK
and the US with a lot more deaths so
zerikovid bought time but China didn't
use it well instead of using it to
vaccinate so improve its medical system
it poured vast resources into testing
like this into lockdowns
it's a bit of a chicken egg
the problem once you're stuck maybe like
China was in this kind of ID that you
could really suppress effectively the
transmission of a virus maybe there was
not this kind of urgency that wasn't
needed to get people vaccinated and
think about the future
as a result China has a very low rate of
elderly vaccination the figure for two
doses aren't bad but only 68 and a half
percent this blue line of people aged
over 60 have received a booster and
that's vital Hong Kong had similarly low
levels of vaccination amongst the
elderly and when Omicron surged out of
control there it recorded the highest
death rate the world had seen now Hong
Kong is interesting for another reason
the population had received a mix of
Western and Chinese vaccine there's been
doubts about the effectiveness of
Chinese vaccines and one study showed
that two doses of Biotech or Pfizer were
much more effective than coronavac the
Chinese vaccine against severe illness
and death but three doses of either
vaccine were just as effective as each
other so the problem isn't the type of
vaccine is that not enough people had
had it and there's another issue for
China an underdeveloped Health Care
system this is the number of intensive
care beds per person in various
countries and China is all the way down
this league table with just 3.6 beds per
hundred thousand people as a result of
that experts have predicted that an
unchecked spread would simply overwhelm
China's Health Care System there'd be
nearly three million admissions to
intensive care and more than one and a
half million deaths now all of those
problems might be fixed with the
political will but China has trumpeted
its zero covert policy as proof of the
superiority of its system compared to
other countries the problem is that
Chinese people are looking at other
countries and thinking their life there
seems a lot better
prime minister talking about China last
night actually at mansion house we'll
bring that to you in more detail later
on you can check it out of course online
as well as Sky news.com and check out
our Twitter feed as well world's largest
active volcano has been erupting in
Hawaii it's the first time in nearly
four decades that Mauna Loa has erupted
moraloa has been started to erupt for
the first time as I said in nearly four
decades the words are like I said twice
footage shows the sky seemingly turning
red above the volcano it last erupted in
1984.
tie now for a look through some of the
photos that have caught our eye this
morning uh meet morak she's the new
southern white rhino calf at a safari
park near Sterling she's just six weeks
old and is already here having her
weigh-in as one of the parks Keepers
gives her a comforting rub the
difference between white and black
rhinos is not the color of the Rhino
it's the shape of their mouth here every
day is a school day and it's beginning
to look a bit like Christmas here in
London Trafalgar Square's Christmas tree
has arrived all the way from Norway it's
a little on the droopy side for now and
if that doesn't take you fancy hair back
this a Couture Christmas tree has been
put up in the v a museum in London
Christmassy or creepy
I'm going B let me know what you think
uh coming up we'll speak to former
England footballer Paul and Arsenal
player poor person to get his Take On
the World Cup so far
[Music]
hello goody uh welcome back to the
breakfast show here on Sky News let's
look at some of today's other headlines
for you let's talk about Elon Musk he's
accused Apple of threatening to remove
Twitter from its app store without
reason in a series of tweets the
platform's owner also said apples
Twitter's biggest Advertiser had halted
spending there's been no comment from
Apple though the tech giant has removed
all tweets from its account
a multi-million pound trial has been
launched to help find flu treatments
quickly this winter the initiative which
was previously used to find cures for
covid will recruit patients admitted to
hospital with severe infections over the
next two years experts have warned there
could be a record number of cases this
year with some potentially
life-threatening
the high level of continuous football as
people pass through Westminster Hall in
the house of parliament to see the queen
lying in state ended up damaging its
Stone floors more than 250 000 people
saw the queen lying in state queuing for
hours along the banks of the Thames
before filing through the ancient Hall
24 hours a day for about five days
apparently it was the carpet that they
put down that was glued to the floor
that damaged it we were hearing from the
culture secretary earlier she said
however much it costs it'll be fine
we'll fix it she was a monarch we needed
to send her off in style
any report has found a majority of
people are concerned about the cost of
Christmas dinner this year amid the cost
of living crisis a survey by the
Salvation Army also found almost one in
five people expect to use items from a
food bank this festive season
turned to the Salvation Army about that
shortly meantime the Spanish Coast Guard
says it has rescued three migrants who
stowed away on the rudder of a tanker
when it arrived in the Canary Islands
can you see them can you see them just
there let me show you
there we go
my goodness to me what sort of
desperation must it be for you to feel
that you have to sit there for 10 days
if you move you're dead
the men were found on a tanker when it
came into Las Palmas after an 11-day
Journey from Lagos in Nigeria and a
photo released by the Coast Guard shows
them sitting in the rudder just above
the water line
now we're building up to tonight's
Battle of Britain England versus Wales
Lions versus dragons Wales needs to beat
England by four goals to cause an upset
and block England from progressing will
they be able to do it let's speak to
former England and Arsenal footballer
Paul Merson hi Paul not used to seeing
you this time in the morning good
morning to you how do you think it's
going to go
morning oh yeah I I expect England to go
but they're not going to lose four Nils
so whatever happens they're going
through but it'll be nice to get back to
winning ways again before it gets into
The Knockout stages and we start you
know getting into the nitty-gritty but
yeah you know these games you've seen
them all before you know it'll be a hard
game this is Wales his biggest game
probably in their in their history
tonight and and England have to be up
for it
uh yeah I mean let's see if the dragons
can breathe fire
um are you hopeful that they might have
a good game
ah if I'm being honest I'm not faster if
I was to have a good game or not if I'm
being honest but I am in Finland now
I've got a few good whales Welsh mates
who'll be watching this guy I'm mad now
but yeah I mean it's all about England
tonight for me uh and hopefully we get
back to winning wise it was poor the
other night it was poor but that's what
happens in tournament football you you
have your ups and downs you've got to
ride your luck we got lucky we drew the
game you know if we win this game we've
won the group which was in miles was a
pretty difficult group if I'm being
honest
um yeah yeah
um talk to us about your memories of
playing for England
um 24 years ago I think what it was in
France wasn't it 98
yeah 98 yeah yeah
so that's soon gone quickly that 24
years that's for sure uh yeah I mean
it's the Pinnacle your career you know
to be a professional football is is
majorly difficult in itself but then
it's a golden play for your England in a
country where this is our national sport
and and you're one of the best 22
players at the time to get picked for
your countries is a is a major thing and
these players you know realize that this
is this is huge you know to play in a
World Cup some people are lucky and they
get to play in three and fours and
whatever but you know I was lucky enough
to play in one World Cup and you know I
always remember that it was a massive
feat for me yeah plenty of money is
going to be spent on betting isn't it on
tonight's match
um as someone who has openly struggled
previously uh with uh with gambling
addiction what's your advice for anybody
who's thinking about betting on
tonight's game
yeah there's a lot of people out there
take a bit normally you know I'm not
gonna there is it's like a lot of people
can drink normally so you know it's not
about people who can do it for Funk and
do it for fun but it's the people that
struggle who've got that compulsion of
the obsessions of gambling you know it
is important to be careful you know even
it might be someone's first bet ever
tonight you know who knows it might be
someone who goes you know what I'm gonna
have my first bet it's England Wales and
this is where it starts and this is
going to be the problem you know it's
it's it's a it's an obsession it's a
it's the probably the worst well it's my
worst addiction out of the free that
I've struggled with more than anything
you don't have to put anything in you
and there's lots of help out there but
it does start somewhere people think oh
you know I won't be a compulsive gamble
I won't struggle with gambling who knows
you know it's that first bet it's like
the first drink it's like the first drug
and and that it's so important there's a
lot of help out there with talk ban stop
you know and it's going from there but
with me you know I struggle badly and I
won't want to put anybody else in that
position you know what I had to go
through Paul how does do our viewers who
might be in a similar how do they stop a
few bets getting out of hand
uh by nipping it in a bad early doors it
is hard I mean it's the time around you
know coming up to Christmas again with
the World Cup at this time of the year
you know a big tournament like this you
know it's the it's Christmas you know
people a lot a lot of people are short
of money you know I just see there in in
your headlines one of them that there is
a lot of shortage of money and people
might think this is the easy way out you
know I'll have a bet you know I'll
England to beat Wales if they win that
and then they'll pay for my Christmas
presents that it doesn't work like that
and then all of a sudden you're in it
and you thought behind and it just gets
further and further and deeper and
that's how it starts that's how it all
starts and people got to be careful
there's a lot a lot of football at the
moment you know ten one four seven you
know you're watching all them games
you know it's difficult not to have a
bet for some people when you know if you
sat in an airdresser for for the whole
date by the end of the day you probably
have an air cut wouldn't you otherwise
there's no point sitting in the
addresses
that's an interesting way of looking at
it
um how well do you think England are
going to do
uh I I think that I think they'll do
well if it's an open tournament I don't
think anybody's great in it I don't
think anybody's ripping it up I think
we've got to get lucky gotta get the
good draw and then we've got to go from
there but I think you know the most
important thing is is they get they get
through the group which they will if
they lost four nil tonight oh my god wow
they'll be coming home on a dinghy I
think they might be a flyer
talk to me um about all the aggravation
with the one love armband
um would you have worn it if you'd been
the captain going out
you know why it's not I don't really get
involved in this guy I mean I I'm not
that you know you know I mean I'm not
the brightest Geezer in the world so I
really get I don't get involved in
politics and things like that I think
you know I'm not clever enough to get
involved in that it's hard for Harry
Kane if he wears it and then he gets
banned for one game you know and then it
doesn't do anybody any favors you know I
I don't agree with a World Cup being
where it is I have I have strong
thoughts on that as well I don't think
it's right I think people are allowed to
live their life out they want to live
their life and and everybody should be
happy and that's the way it is I don't
think people should have their lives run
for them I just don't think that's right
yeah uh but uh going back to the
football you're hopeful that um England
will progress through and who knows I'm
not I'm not hopeful okay I'm absolutely
sure they will get through if they lost
four nil I would be I'd be shocked he'll
be the biggest shock in the history of
football
if england lost it wouldn't be but if
they lost four nil it would be yeah um
the big game I suppose that a lot of
people keep pointing me towards is the
France game we need to be France
we need to stop in Buffet that's what we
have to do I mean they're very good he's
for me he's the best player in the world
as we talked today he has everything he
could beat players he crosses the boy
scores goals you can head it he can
dribble the lad's got everything I think
he's 22 23 years of age it's phenomenal
absolute phenomenal plot we need we need
Carl Walker back obviously now that Rhys
James isn't fit we need Carl Walker fit
for that game otherwise I think we will
struggle
yeah and who's your favorite England
player at the moment who's your most uh
who is the most impressive England
player at the moment
or most impressive in England player you
know what I'm going to go for our at the
moment I thought Harry MaGuire was
outstanding the other night it takes a
lot a lot of the bottle what he does you
know to turn up and go on that pitch
with the pressure that's on him and and
he never lets England down I couldn't
talk highly enough for the bloke I
thought he was outstanding the other
night and I don't if he played the other
night I think we get beat by the USA so
for me at the moment I'm gonna go with
Harry MaGuire and especially with all
the pressure on the lad as well I mean I
take my off to him fair play his big
pressure plan for England it's been even
bigger pressure plan for England for
Harry MaGuire in the last two games and
he's not again he's never let anybody
down
um just before I let you go
um thoughts on the Arsenal how they're
doing at the moment and the impact that
the break in the season might have on
them for the World Cup
you know what they're doing great at the
moment I think when they come back it's
going to be a toss of a coin because can
they come back and play any better I
think the break hasn't done them any
good and then again it might you know a
lot of their players are not playing in
the games or a few of them or not which
is good but only time will tell can I
just say one thing Kate please before I
leave and that's if anybody's struggling
please go to
www.talkbands.com
please please absolutely absolutely I
will put it on our website as well and
we put it on the Twitter feed
um when we're talking about this and
clip it up it's great to see Paul enjoy
your Christmas hopefully we'll see you
soon
bye-bye okay Wolfie says hi thanks a lot
now literally we spoke to the culture
history Michelle uh Donnelly I asked her
what she made of the sports Minister's
decision to wear a one love armband to
tonight's game
I support the uh the campaign behind the
and the sentiment behind the one love
armband and I believe in us being able
to stand up for our values and I'm proud
that he's going to wear that would you
wear one if you went yes I think I would
actually
there you go coming up uh speaking to
Labor's John Ashworth would he wear one
uh also asking him about the online
harms Bill and what they're going to do
about getting people back into work that
to come in just a few moments time
looking ahead to Thursday I'll ask the
Trade union leaders do you support them
do you want to offer them a brick bat or
a bouquet get involved on Twitter we've
got an email address for you as well so
stay tuned
foreign